SPEAKER: Welcome
to "Cloud Minute."
Today I am going to show you
how to create a managed instance
group from the command line.
I'll be using Cloud Shell, but
you can use your own terminal
if you'd prefer.
First we need to create
an instance template.
Name your template.
Set the machine type.
And set a boot disk size.
Additional flags can
be found in the Help.
If you want to see what's in a
given template, use Describe.
Now you can create a
managed instance group
from your template.
Name your group.
Specify the template.
And specify the group size.
Now you've created a managed
instance group using gcloud.
Check out our other
Cloud Minutes.